hi guys it's silver Rhett again with
another episode of their let's play Pike
and yeah this is something special I am
doing a time-lapse and I'm actually
doing commentary at the same time and
actually I've been planning to do this
for a very long time but I'll give the
story since that building will just
build itself in the background but it's
also shoutout to shadow war for TV 5000
for an engine me on this on this thing
but anyway I I talked about I talked
about this thing earlier where I had
like people who wanted time lapses and
people wanted to comment out and I was
like yeah I can't cater to all of you so
I'll just kind of do both sometimes but
then I figured I've got some recorded
material I might as well put it all into
Sony Vegas put it into one very fast
yeah
time lapse and then do commentary over
that so that's what I'm doing right now
and just building that stupid building
over there just panning that little
thing which pretty much took an entire
episode last time because it's this time
that's this pretty fast but yeah it's
just some medieval / Alpine stuff I felt
like I wanted to and loads of buildings
on flew builded I Heights entire Rocky
thing I had going on there sins the
thing with this ride was to imitate that
feeling in a tech and Titan you've got
these three leave maneuver gears and
which they used to fly around buildings
and stuff like that and have epic battle
scenes and everything the animation was
gorgeous in that and like kind of
imitate that feeling and idea with this
ride have the ride like go in between
these buildings do all kinds of curves
and fly around around these things have
some scenery interaction that's
basically was what I was going for and
yeah with this tower rich and it just
turned out that I could use gears and
stick him on this tower and make it look
steampunk because obviously not actually
annoys some people I know I've been
talking to Heather earth and he was like
yeah you should not do that
and I was figuring I'm gears I'm pipe to
make everything steampunk to my [ __ ]
but yeah that's one problem that comes
with this park the fact that
steampunk is not just the gears in the
cogs in the pipes and that and
all the steam [ __ ] and chimneys it's
also the architecture in general but the
problem is that I was an idiot a total
idiot went into this park thinking you
know what I can do everything I'm just
going to make a medieval Alpine
steampunk park mate while not realizing
well of course it's kind of realizing
but not realizing that that would make
no freakin sense so now I'm here stuck
with this theme that nobody's had ever
done before nobody has ever done before
with good reasons and yeah so now I'm
struggling with this terraforming it's
terraforming which is absolutely
annoying in roller-coaster country
trying to trying to make a little
restaurant that looks somewhat decent
and trying to kind of get into that old
style again way it's more medieval than
the part of Laguna de Fora Heights since
I basically wanted to kind of mix it up
a little have different Park sections
with bit with different kinds of theming
it would all be the same general sense
of steampunky medieval stuff but in
different ways and using different sets
and different objects along the way so
the entrance part is it's very castle
ish many castles and same goes for the
restaurant now I'm working on right now
a lot of station gems costs all set
since I figured that would work out with
Ralphie's medieval sets and this
restaurant it's gonna be a very simple
restaurant mainly it's going to be about
that little building over there and then
you know it would just be some medieval
stuff over here and then the flu girl if
I hide Speights had more of those Alpine
ish buildings since it was on a rock and
supposed to be somewhat more well on a
higher elevation basically and then what
I want to try to do with the inputs that
I'm building is actually do the same
thing as I did with a free fly coaster
but with some other colors and other
kind of kinds of textures and when it
comes to this restaurant it's just
basically the same style as well another
style holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
I should not voice Greg like that but
it's basically the same kind of style as
the rest of the entrance Plaza with like
with that fountain in the middle and
just earth just all those castles around
it so it's the same deal very actually
very in a sense unoriginal
this is something that many people have
done before I just figured that the
steampunky is an element that could add
to it so that's why I added those zero
G's little trims and pillows and iron
stuff but after all it's still a castle
and you have random towers random roofs
everything that comes with a medieval
castle and it's been done so many times
before in ICD 3 it's been done till to
death basically so I just wanted to do
something else but it didn't quite come
up that great so that kind of sucks but
this restaurants looking kind of decent
but still kind of mad and I'm gonna have
to work on the interiors at some point
because I didn't feel like doing that
this time
because interiors is stupid I don't like
doing them but I should at some point
and then I just add some base walls and
some of those arches from well silver at
steampunk stuff because it needs to be
at least somewhat steampunk ish some
lights well and some copper stuff to
kind of make it seem like it's actual
steampunk which is kind of isn't but I
guess that's a decent addition to that
to the plaza so I guess I'll just keep
that and now having to mess around with
those conforming fences is never really
fun because I I hate it when you've got
fence sets like it's very flexible but
you've got those fence sets where you
actually post like the wooden beams
first and then have the posts and that's
flexible what it takes a lot of time and
these all our parts are great but you
can see me struggling over here because
obviously there are no pieces for that
specific thing that no straight to
diagonal pieces and there's some going
to be some more struggling with me with
that holo extend yeah I actually did
struggle with that I cut it out I think
at some point I've really had major
problems with that set also deleting all
that all of those lights because they
look like
who basically and replacing them with
those because they're just a little bit
more subtle and less out there I still
feel like it's so hard when you've got a
path that's kind of sloped like this one
because not all of the sets conform it's
really hard to add anything you can't
really add normal planters and buildings
to it it's very hard to kind of make
that look less boring but yeah I think
in general you know this is I think the
pie - yeah and here's the part where I
had no clue how to use this set just
endless crawling around nothing and
still me - it'd be great if somebody who
actually knew something about this
station shims station Jim Jr's random
things who actually knew about that set
so like I don't know I feel like there
needs to be a cart or something
underneath here but I totally missed the
point of that so it's just places stupid
Disney thing over there might as well do
that and I have no idea why the railings
on the on the top spin we're visible
over there and now it's time for some
more planters because basically if your
paths look boring just add a lot of
planters to them and they probably look
decent at some point and put loads of
nice flowers in them because I know I
like flowers I'm not even kidding I like
flowers I like doing flowers just
scrolling through those things and
making nice little flower patches I
don't know why but I just like doing
that and of course I'm just gonna add
some small foliage in the middle of that
planter thing and speaking of flowers
this is one big flower fest over here
it's going to be loads of space for
flowers so adding that alongside small
ones and some bigger ones that's
basically how you should build it up the
smallest flowers should be next to the
path and then if you want to have more
flowers further away from the path you
can always use some larger ones but it
makes no sense to have smaller ones away
from the path because you won't be able
to really see them so that's why I'm
trying to get the high winds in the back
also make sure that your flowers are
next to paths because people need to
maintain that stuff realistically
speaking flower is far away from parts
to make no sense
unless they're wild flowers and just
some hedges just because I want more a
small foliage it's always a very
important
if you want to spice it up a little but
anyway thanks for watching that was
about it for this episode until the next
one